is absolutely fiery
there's 30 000 people on the cliff
there's more hype there's more ego
there's more Fame and that all leads up
to one Breaking Point
[Music]
something about the way he'll believe in
you I love seeing people accomplishing
their goals their dreams doing what they
love for me surfing is a religion it's a
mix of pure adrenaline fear and
happiness and I do it because I love it
if I don't have the smile on my face
it's not worth it I've always seen her
like a superhero nothing can happen to
her
this is what I want to do for the rest
of my life
every season you want to perform you
want to do your best it will make your
career or break it you need to push
yourself if you want to succeed
sometimes I feel like it's too much
I want to prove that I'm not the kid
anymore
the fear and the love the stress
why do I need such an extreme
circumstance
in order to feel alive oh my God I don't
see him anywhere
I've never seen Nicole so afraid
if you needed me to be there for her
the biggest enemy that you have to
overcome is your own mind when you start
doubting yourself you might not come
home at all
or realize we put everything on the line
no that sometimes we only get one shot
[Music]
thank you